we welcome in the new champ of fortnight
Kyle bugga gears door if the 16 year old
professional fortnight player who joins
us here in the man cave fortnight is a
video game that involves 100 players
dropping on to a virtual island and
fighting to be the last one standing
while a storm brews in the background
draining the players of health points
fortnight developer Epic Games said the
tournament was the most participated in
tournament of all time if I told you two
years ago
Kyle you were gonna be winning three
million dollars playing fortnight you
would have said what I just said that's
unreal I wouldn't believe it
honestly okay how did this start first
time you played fortnight what happened
first time I played for and I was like
on the ps4 I'm pretty sure and I was
just playing with my friend just having
a good time you know just for fun and
then yeah we just got a few wins here
and there and then we enjoyed the game
and I just kept with like kept playing
but what was it about this that you just
said I can't get enough of it probably
like the building and just like winning
the games honestly like working your way
up to the victory that's all like I
really wanted if somebody had never
played fortnight like yours truly how
would you explain this game and why I
need to play this I'd explain it like
it's a bad already out pretty much so
you have to be the last one standing and
the way you'd play it is you can get
with a bunch of friends and just get
online and just practice together and
try to get a win when did you know you
were good I think I knew I was like
better than the average fire like six
months ago probably it was like the
middle like the middle gap between when
I was playing what was different it was
like I was performing all in tournaments
and doing well and like scrimmages so I
got a new what are you doing while
you're playing online are you are you
standing are you nervous uh no I'm
pretty much just sitting in my chair
just you know relaxing it's my setup so
I'm used to it so pretty much just
playing and then what did mom and dad
say when you started to play more than
you probably should have they wanted to
make sure I was getting my schoolwork
done and doing well in school and really
like a lot of timing yeah I did okay
soon good alright great point averages
one mmm what is it my grade point
average yeah
it was high it was like high three like
low four oh there okay so that that
would allow you to play more for tonight
yeah pretty much that was it but they
never said get outside and get some
fresh air you know they wanted me out
like hanging out with my friends and all
that so so be social with everyone and
then I I know you're on with Jimmy
Kimmel and I think you talked about your
routine where you you work on your hands
for thirty minutes before you start what
does that mean so that's like creative
in the game for a night you can go in
and you can work on your builds so
pretty much that's what I do for like 30
minutes and then I actually go to
playing the game how long does the game
normally take 23 minutes if it plays so
I like the final final zone and then you
would lock in for 6 or 7 hours wouldn't
you in play yeah pretty much
does mom just put like food under the
door like what what happens sometimes
I'll come in you know they'll give me
food every now and then and then other
times Otis go down make some real quick
and then come back up when did you first
get paid to play I think I got paid to
play early March that's when I got
officially signed to my team but also I
was getting paid to play from like then
game tournaments and stuff like that and
what would be the the normal pay that
you would get generally not like you won
the three million dollars mmm these
first contracts are weird so it's like
hard to say exactly it can range
anywhere from like two thousand to ten
thousand depending on the player first
paycheck was what it was like around the
middle of that pretty much okay and then
you get the three million mm-hmm what do
you do then same thing get home just
play the game that's a do you go to the
ATM and just look do you even have an
ATM card I think I think I have a debit
card yeah oh you think you do okay but
but do you just go and bring your
friends over to the bank and get that
receipt and just not oh you don't do
that no why would I I'd be saying look
at that right there
no I'm not humble though like you like I
would be sure well wait you were dancing
like when you won like you you showed
some personality there like after I
wanted like holding up the trophy
yeah I'm gonna be a little bit excited
the adrenaline okay now what should like
on social media where you got
you do this as well okay and are they
coming after you like you're now a
target I mean everyone kind of just sees
it as like a way they can get better
pretty much like they see then it's kind
of motivation like after every
tournament and people usually see people
win they're like wow I want to get out
there and do the same thing and when
there's no trash talking I mean usually
when people land on you like at your
spot pretty much that's when their trash
talk comes in you know so you've faced
some of that yeah a little bit
do you trash drunk uh every now and then
like what would you say you know you
just tell them to get out of your spot
you know they lost five times in a row
oh okay all right I like that
age isn't is age restriction here or is
there a sweet spot to be is 16 is it a
benefit to be 16 playing for it I mean I
think being younger in this game is like
really good because it's like all about
your reaction time and how quick you are
so the age limit though to compete is 13
so you have to be 13 oh yeah I think
it's a good spot what do you want to do
for a living probably be like a streamer
the that's gonna be the are you going to
college possibly I wanna say like how
far this goes possibly sounds like a no
there's a chance okay but I thought
someone close to you said hey he's going
to college I overheard that in the
hallway did someone say that yes they
did didn't hear you no sources close to
you said hey he's going to yes Paul I
just heard dad say I just hope he stays
in high school
are you a big deal in high school I mean
I'm doing online school now oh yeah okay
well you're missing out on cashing in I
mean you're gonna be big man on campus
I mean it's whatever I don't want to
wake up at 6:30 you know oh but you got
other things to do so is your school
curriculum then based off of what you're
doing with fortnight the curriculum as
in like you're doing it online so that
allows you to spend more time to
important exactly yeah Wow
pretty good scam you pulled on your
parents here like I don't have to go to
school
I study online I get to play fortnight
all day and night yeah there yeah what
did you get mom for did you did you buy
anybody anything with this three mil no
I don't even think I bought myself
anything no you gotta do
mom and dad I haven't done anything in I
know but they allowed you how about get
your dad a truck or something a truck
yeah wait you got three million dollars
I'm just telling you as a father if you
were my son I say I would say it'd be
nice that I got a piece of this cuz I
allowed you to do this you didn't earn
it so good I did earn it I said to mom
let him do it he's gonna be successful
one day he'll be a champion hun you
think now who championed your cause more
mom or dad mmm that's hard I don't know
I don't think either I think they both
were like really happy for me oh all
right do you have brothers sisters have
a sister yeah okay
how does just think gee I don't know how
she like thinks about everything pretty
much like I she's just there and she's
just going with it
I don't know how she feels honestly wait
you how's the relationship there she oh
yeah okay so what is what's the next
tournament next tournaments probably
middle of September and how many people
will be involved it's still gonna be
like a hundred people in the actual
finals how do you get into the finals
you have to compete through like weekend
tournaments and weekly tournaments and
you have to get like top six in which
this is trios so you have to be top six
trio okay and then there'll be 100
people just like there were when you won
the three million yeah pretty much okay
and then after that how many - how many
terms do you have a year terms as in
like tournaments yeah it can depend
imeem they don't have like a full
schedule so it's kind of just random
whatever like whenever they put all
tournaments is when we played pretty
much who came up with the nickname or
your your hand Eluga yeah my grandpa
okay and that is in regards to that's
just when I was a little baby you just
said booga-booga that's pretty much it
so that's your handle yeah what's the
best handle you've heard that's handle
like best best name that somebody goes
by there good character names out there
I mean I don't really think about them
not really oh I mean there's there's you
know unique ones I think mine's pretty
unique oh it is yeah yeah do you play
sports yeah
suffice first I don't really eat too
much anymore though I retired already at
six but started a new career what do you
what did you play I played basketball
soccer I played pretty much every sport
but basketball and soccer mainly
favorite teams you're from Pennsylvania
yes so the 76ers in basketball well we
can go with the Eagles okay
and then I don't really care too much
about any of the others have you run
into celebrities with Fortnight
elaborate is yeah like athletes and you
know they tend to play online people I
don't think like in game I don't think I
ran into them okay but fortnight's huge
yes yeah so I'm good how many people
play fortnight I don't even know the
number and you have a lot of stars from
Europe yeah why is that I think I'm not
sure honestly I think they just caught
up on the game and they saw there was
money involved and he probably just
played in there's a huge population over
there it's bigger than ours who for
Knight who was the best before you won
three million dollars who did you
consider the best consider the best
probably myself
wait before you one yeah you gotta have
them in Tautou going into it okay let's
say before six months ago when you
realize you were good you don't want to
give anybody credit I mean I I think I
looked up to people to learn things from
but I don't think I had I guess at best
just because that's how the game is I
don't think there's really like a set
best player I think everyone can be like
really good but some people are you know
a little bit above could you teach older
people to play like does your your
parents play yeah my dad tries to play
but it's not good at all
wine I just kind of slow you know he's
slow yeah he's not too fast on it
Wow okay but you can't teach an older
person new tricks me I could maybe if
they can pick up on it yeah sure how
much math go like what what is the key
ingredient that you what you have to
have if you're gonna be good at this I
mean if you're just playing for fun it's
just kind of like how you engage your
fights but in scrims it's pretty much
all about your positioning and like how
you get to those places
hey there's so much in the game it's
like crazy McLovin do you play fortnight
I played it are you any good no I'm
terrible I get beat there's
our neighbors of fourth grade and fifth
grade and they're dominating me although
I have a good attitude and like I'm a
Philly guy we were tough competitors
you know how long would he last against
you yeah probably a minute a minute yeah
give him a minute no no is it have you
allowed people to stay longer and you
sort of toy with them maybe if it's the
last person alive I'm like a public game
maybe yeah did you do that with the
tournament like you realized before you
won that you would want I mean in the
tournament I was kind of just trying to
pick up on all the free kills I could
get at the very end there and just kind
of capitalize on it so you took a
victory lap before the victory lap
pretty much yeah yeah if I have you back
in ten years
yes McLovin whoa ah if you want to play
miss pac-man on the other head or
centipede are you good at any other
video game huh I mean on the console I
was good but not on PC like World of
Warcraft you only good and never play it
no never played that all right McLovin
you might have a shot have you ever
played like an arcade style like
standalone game I don't think so
you don't have time for that I mean it
depends on what game yes I mean yes Paul
World of Warcraft is so 2016 Dan no no
no mom well you can't win that kind of
money in the world of work right now
where you can't on for tonight all right
do yourself a favor mm-hmm get mom and
dad something okay just something nice
you know whatever you want to do just
something that's nice like a nice
convertible maybe a truck be nice all
right
you got three mil okay okay I'll think
about it yeah yeah in ten years from now
I hope you don't say I still got that
three million in the bank
I hope you spend a little more oh yeah I
expect you yeah you're gonna have a
little bit more yeah good luck with this
thank you yeah and ten years from now
when we have you back you'll be doing
what probably so be stream and playing
video games hopefully living at home uh
I mean my own house okay by then you'll
be the old guy in the room ten years
from now
yeah probably then you have young punks
taking a piece of you there yeah he's
Kyle booga years Dorf net1 fortnight and
won three million dollars and he still
has three million dollars because he
won't give anything to mom and dad
thank you for coming in yeah thank you
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]